Ciao Guglielmo ciao ospite, in pratica un giorno sono
andato a dormire a casa di questo mio
amico, mi sveglio la mattina dopo per andare al bagno, questo c'ha il
bagno in camera, ho trovato che stava in pratica nudo
aveva messo l'orso della sorella, tipo
quegli orsacchiotti grandi sul lavandino
e si stava ingroppando l'orso. Al che gli dico "Oh ma che stai facendo?", e questo si
gira nudo con questo orso che gli copre il pacco.
-Io per l'imbarazzo non avrei mai detto
"Oh ma che stai facendo?" - E' la cosa che mi
turba di più di tutto il racconto. Io avrei fatto "Bah"
Povera la ragazza. "Amore non ti depilare". Se Toy Story fosse vero:"Posso superare questo momento
Non è vero! Sono un bugiardo! - Shh piano piano!"
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della
puntata di oggi è "Amici Strani"
Per una puntata così importante ho
pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios de casa mia innanzitutto una delle persone che
mi conosce meglio al mondo e che quindi più
di chiunque altro ha testimoniato la mia
sanità mentale e inoltre uno degli
ospiti secondo me più amati a seconda di
quello che leggo dai vostri commenti qui
su questo canale
Purtroppo non poteva venire, quindi alla
fine abbiamo optato per Claudia Genolini
- Eheheh - La prossima volta metterò delle lance
qui  - Salve a tutti buona sera
Allora sai che cosa non apprezzo molto? - Dimmi - Che sei magra. Mi fai sembrare una giumenta
Vai più avanti, almeno capito sembri più grande - Vuoi che mi metto tipo...Avrai  un po' di cose da dire
evitiamo di dirne troppe - Io al liceo avevo un caro
amico che con la pelle morta delle mani
lui se le sfogliava piano piano piano piano.
Aveva fatto con una penna un buco nel
banco e ogni giorno riempiva questo
buco di queste palline - Che Schifo!
Io preferirei una ziggurat di caccole,
una sciarpa di palline dell'ombelico
Faceva questo - No perché sfogliava - No che schifo!
Stuccando ha riempito... - Che schifo! Hai visto la carne quando marcisce?
- Ciao Guglielmo ciao ospite, io ho un amico che si veste da pirata e che viaggia a piedi ovunque lui vada
qualsiasi cosa deve fare lui ci va a piedi
e una volta si è fatto il giro
d'Italia a piedi, stile Forrest Gump proprio.
"Ma perché fa questo? Avevo voglia di correre"
Ha paura delle formiche perché pensa che gli possano entrare dentro l'orecchio e mangiarselo
Ha bevuto il petrolio, ha mangiato un pezzo di sua sorella
Direi che basta così, tu che dici? - Ha mangiato un pezzo
di sua sorella? L'ha detto o ho capito male
io? - Comunque credo sia alla base proprio
della sua dieta. E' come l'ananas - Non mi torna la cosa del pirata, cioè è un pirata ma
va in giro a piedi, non va con la nave?
- Perché non c'è il mare - Quindi va in giro
e fa "Cazzalaranda!"- No va in giro su una canoa
seduto sull'asfalto...Due bicipiti "così".
- Ciao Guglielmo e ciao ospite, penso di
avere una delle amiche più strane del
mondo. Ha tante particolarità, però una
delle più inquietanti ma affascinanti e
allo stesso tempo, è che sa parlare
completamente storto. E se non ci credi
guarda, ce l'ho proprio qua. Ciao Marty
presentati - (Linguaggio al contrario) - Ma parla russo?
- E se non siete ancora convinti
adesso vi facciamo qualche altro esempio
Grattacielo - Oleicattarg - Asciugamano - Onamaguicsa - Libreria - Airerbil
- Lampadario - Oiradampal - Occhiali -Ilaihcco
- Supercalifragilistichespiralidoso - Naaa - Ecco
non la sa questa, mi dispiace. Le voglio un
sacco di bene però è strana - Lo dice veramente
al contrario - Enrico in montaggio
prendi quello che dice e lo ribalti? Vai!
Adesso stiamo ascoltando. Vai! - Libreria - Libreria -Asciugamano - Grattacielo - Grattacielo - Faccio delle
reazioni capito? - Occhiali - Occhiali - Lampadario - Lampadario
Icid ozzac... - Armadio - Oida...mra
Oidambra non è armadio - Perché stanno ridendo?
Ciao Gu sappi che ti amo, un saluto anche all'ospite. Sono triste di essere etero e vorrei cambiare idea
per te però sappi che io conosco questo mio amico
qua, che ogni mattina prende la bilancia
per pesare la droga hai presente? L'erba
- Non abbiamo presente
- Quindi prende il peso delle fette biscottate e
ci aggiunge per forza, senno' mi ha detto
che non riesce ad andare avanti per la
giornata, 8 grammi di marmellata per
ognuna e quindi fa 12 grammi di fetta
biscottata più 8 di marmellata per 3
marmellate in modo da fare 3 fette biscottate
perfette da 20 grammi - In tutto questo a
me mi ha turbato la bilancia per la droga
- Io andrei avanti sulla bilancia per la droga
e fingerei di non averlo mai sentito il momento di Breaking Bad:"Di il mio nome!
Sei Heisenberg. Hai maledettamente ragione!" - Io
sono un pochino ossensivo, ossessivo
C'hai le fisse tue. Tu vai a periodi, non hai sempre la
stessa fissa, cioè non sei coerente nelle tue fisse
- No ma non sono coerente in generale. Tu
sei quella lì tipo che non sa usare la
diplomazia - Io sono la regina del
bipolarismo - Tu sei la regina delle "S****a ti odio!"
Io conoscevo una persona ossessiva
compulsiva e la conoscevi anche tu - Matteo Bruno
♫Matteo Bruno Matteo Bruno Matteo Bruno Matteo Bruno Matteo Bru u no♫
- Beh a parte Matteo Bruno. Matteo non
metteva mai i calzini dello stesso colore
Ciao Guglielmo ciao Gianmarco che ascolta i messaggi ciao ospite, una volta parlavo con una mia amica
riguardo ad alcune fisse e lei mi confida che non riesce a dormire tranquilla se
le sue scarpe non sono perfettamente posizionate una a fianco all'altra. Mi ha anche confidato
che se un giorno ad esempio
delle scarpe nuove le fanno
particolarmente male oppure si stanca
a camminare e quindi le fanno male i piedi
lei per punizione non le mette vicino la
notte ma le mette lontane, una da una parte
una dall'altra. Se addirittura le fanno dei tagli e delle
vesciche le lancia e le sbatte da una parte all'altra sempre per punizione
"Cattiva, cattiva!" - Perché lei magari si immagina le
scarpe che fanno "No, non ci dividere!"
Qual è la cosa più strana che fai tu? - Non so quanto sia strana, mi piace credere che sia una cosa che fanno
più persone, faccio tipo delle scommesse
con me stesso, tipo
se il semaforo scatta al tre allora
succede questo. Oppure faccio il
giochetto pari disparo, cioè disparo
succede una cosa, pari succede un'altra
cosa, quindi incomincio a fare uno due, tre quattro, e
quando scatta tu sai che o succede una
cosa o succede un'altra cosa - Beh io direi che
è un'ottima materia di studio - E poi mi mangio le feci!
Tu invece? - Questa cosa delle scommesse la
faccio anch'io - Non puoi copiarmi - Mangio le feci!
Enrico è il peggio di tutti. Enrico è su un altro pianeta - Non è vero, te me fai 3 0 Gu (Enrico)
Onesto Giammi lo accetto - Lui è più...è meno str (Gianmarco) - E' meno strano e più disconnesso però?
Enrico è più un disturbato - Adesso si è spostato l'argomento ma Guglielmo è più strano
- Sono stato bravo a spostarlo andiamo avanti
Chi è il più strano della famiglia? - Tu (Enrico) - Io avevo fatto una classifica (Gianmarco)
Nel podio mettevo te, Gabriele e Beatrice se non sbaglio (Gianmarco)
- Quindi Lavinia tranquilla...una persona sana. C'è la scala Richter della pazzia
- Avete i prototìpi no? - I prototipi - No si può dire anche prototìpi - O prototipò
- Beh anche la risata di tuo fratello è importante - Vediamo se riusciamo a farlo ridere - Ma è di famiglia?
Io ho notato che tua madre ha la stessa
risata. Non la fa adesso non la fa
- Guardalo con giudizio, pensa delle
cose brutte su di lui mentre lo guardi, vere
Ci sta cascando...*risata enrico*
Ho un amico che si diverte tantissimo a
spoilerare i finali dei film, delle serie tv a chiunque
- Però questo non è essere strani,
questo è essere s****i! - Si. Col tempo lo capirai
perché rimani solo più che altro, cioè
come dire "Un mio amico si diverte un
sacco a incendiarsi le scoregge contro la gente". Magari col tempo imparerà quando rimarrà solo
Dracarys - Dracarys
Tu l'hai mai fatto? Fare le puzze con
l'accendino sul sedere, io non l'ho mai
fatto - Mica sei strana. "Vorrei tanto
farlo stavi per dire?" - Siii. Però bisogna farlo col jeans perché sennò c'è il ritorno di fiamma e
muori. Se volete farlo fatelo con i jeans
- No non fatelo è pericolosissimo - Ma perché io lo voglio fare troppo - Ma hai 30 anni - Ma che vuol dire? - E ti vuoi
incendiare il culo? Ma tu sei pazza! - Perché? Pensa che bello questa fiammano blu, perché poi il metano c'ha dei
colori strani, un po' tipo l'aurora boreale del c**o
- L'aurora borettale?
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, questo mio amico era alle prime armi con il motorino, così il padre si offrì
volontario per fargli fare delle guide. In
una di queste volte lui acquistò troppa
velocità, rendendosi conto troppo tardi
di una curva. Così pensò bene di
lanciarsi giù dal mezzo lasciando che il
padre si schiantasse da solo contro il muro - No
Lui era alla guida. Ho conosciuto una ragazza che una volta
che ha rosicato col suo ragazzo, stavano
in macchina, e stavano andando abbastanza
veloci. Loro due litigano "Accosta voglio
andarmene!". Tra parantesi sulla tangenziale
tutto questo avveniva. Lei ha buttato la
borsa dal finestrino e ha detto "E ora
accosti ora accosti! - Non me ne frega un c***o della tua borsa - A si?"...Si è fratturata la spalla e le
coste - Le coste? Quelle d'abbacchio - Si dovrebbe dire coste. Tutti quanti i medici la fuori
le costole non sono tipo le costolette
del maiale e le coste sono il costato?
Vabbè le costole, si è rotta le
costole, quindi la cosa più assurda di
questa cosa è che ho detto coste e non che una tizia si è lanciata da una macchina
Io una volta col motorino, prima volta che
salgo, vado per spingerlo per salirci
sopra motore acceso - Spingerlo in che
senso? In che senso spingerlo
- Enrico fai qualcosa. Ho fatto "così" e ho
fatto esplodere il parabrezza, si è divelto a metà
L'ho distrutto sisi. Poi me lo so portato senza il parabrezza
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata, grazie mille per tutti i
messaggi che ci avete mandato. Grazie
soprattutto a Claudio anche per...Claudio
Detto ciò fatemi sapere qua sotto se
conoscete qualche personaggio
particolare, se tra le nostre amicizie si
annovera qualcuno così di peculiare
- Potevi dirla più semplice - Tipo? - Scrivetemi se conoscete qualcuno
de strano qua sotto - E' vero era molto più semplice vabbè
Come sempre io vi
saluto, vi invito a iscrivervi al mio
canale, ai canali di Claudia, a attivare le
notifiche, fare tutto, fate una
giravolta, fatela un'altra volta, mettete un like
Ci vediamo la prossima settimana con un'altra puntata sempre alle 14. Ciao - Ciao